Chaosradio 234, das süße Heimnetz und da wo ich heute mit Hendrik, Jasik und Danimo. Herzlich Willkommen zurück.
Hallo.
Und dem zahlreichen Publikum macht mal Krach. Das ist krass. Ich dachte, jetzt käme so ein Tumbleweed, weil wir sind heute echt nicht viel. Das nächste Mal müsst ihr wieder vorbeikommen in der Marienstraße. Alle zwei Monate senden wir live von vor Ort und man kann dabei sein und manchmal sogar alte gebrauchte Powerline Adapter von Danimo abgreifen. Aber nur fürs Publikum, wenn man da anwesend ist. Wir beschäftigen uns heute mit dem Heimnetzwerk und wollen über alles sprechen, was hinter dem Internetanschluss passieren kann. Wir haben die erste Stunde damit zugebracht, dass wir über den Router, der noch mehr ist, aber sozusagen das Gerät, was das Internet für unsere Wohnung bereit macht, gesprochen und auch, wie man in der ganzen Welt unterwegs sein kann und trotzdem in seinem eigenen Heimnetzwerk ist. Und jetzt kommen wir endlich dazu, dass man sagen kann, ok, was kann man denn noch damit machen, außer seinen Rechner möglichst schnell und dick an den Internetanschluss ranzukriegen. Es fiel schon oft der Begriff NAS. Ist die ältere unter uns erinnernd sicher ein Rapper, aber auch ein, ich bin der Kopf geschüttelt, oh Gott, ich bin der Älteste, aber auch ein Network Attached Storage heißt es eigentlich, oder? Genau. Im Prinzip eine Netzwerk Festplatte. Will man das? Was macht man damit? Und wie sieht das denn gut aus?
Will man das? Will man?
Was kann es denn eigentlich?
Es ermöglicht dir einfach einen Speicherplatz zu haben, der unabhängig von einem speziellen Gerät ist. Man kann das immer am besten aus der Zeit erklären. Früher hatte man den einen Rechner, der irgendwo im Büro stand, da war halt alles drauf. Das ist ja schon lange nicht mehr der Fall. Heute hast du dein Handy, mit dem du Fotos schießt, deine Digitalkamera, die möglicherweise sogar wählernfähig ist, dein Laptop und so weiter. Und alle, die produzieren Daten. Und die kannst du jetzt irgendwie in die Cloud versenden und bei verschiedenen Anbieter ablegen. Aber im Regelfall hast du ja noch viel mehr Daten, die jetzt irgendwo liegen sollen und die willst du vor allen Dingen schnell zugreifen können von zu Hause. Und die kannst du halt auf so einer netzwerkangebundenen Festplatte ablegen. Dabei ist das Ding aber auch noch viel mehr. Nämlich nicht nur eine Festplatte, sondern meistens ist es in der sinnvollen Ausbaustufe, so wie ich das jetzt empfehlen würde, mehrere Festplatten, die das auch vertragen können, wenn mal einer ausfällt.
Also und als Anwendungszweck kommt noch dazu, dass man vielleicht als moderner Benutzer eines Obstgerätes nicht mehr so viel Platz hat.
Ich wäre ein gewisser ein gewisse Missgunst oder? Aber so eine Art, also quasi man kann eine große Festplatte nicht machen, kann man entweder seine Superfotosammlung drauf abladen oder halt ein Backup machen, was man regelmäßig machen soll. Dazu komme ich am Ende der Sendung immer gerne. Also im Prinzip sind das ja kleine Computer, an die man mehrere Festplatten hängt, die dann so konfiguriert sind, dass man manchmal sogar während des Betriebes eine rausnehmen und austauschen kann, also dass quasi die Festplatte kaputt ist, sodass es geht. Das gibt es ja wie alles heutzutage auch als sozusagen fertige Lösung zu kaufen. Gibt es so zwei oder drei große Anbieter, also Cyanology, Western Digital und? So, das sind sozusagen die, die man machen kann.
Und Netgear.
Und Drobo für die Leute, die zu viel Geld haben.
Es ist immer klar sozusagen, es gibt keine Qualitätssiegel vom CCC, aber so generell gesagt, was ist denn von diesen Lösungen zu halten? Also weil die sind ja mehr als nur das Gerät. Die bringen ja immer auch sozusagen eine eigene Bediensoftware mit. Die haben ja auch so einen Web-Interface, über das man die ansteuern kann. Oder ein Programm sozusagen, was man auf dem Rechner laden muss, über das man die ansteuern kann. Ist das generell so was, dass man sagt, das will man eigentlich haben? Oder ist das schon wieder zu viel und der Purist sagt, nee, ich möchte mir das alles selber bauen. Nimm einen Raspberry Pi und stecke da per OSB eine Festplatte dran.
Also man will das natürlich selber bauen, aber wir haben ja am Anfang irgendwas von Heim-Usern gesagt und so. Und da finde ich das schon gar nicht so falsch. Also ich habe selber sowas nicht. Ich habe das bei Bekannten gesehen und war schon so milde ein bisschen beeindruckt. Wenn ich da an dem Web-Interface rumgeklickt habe, das haben offenbar auch Nerds gebaut. Also was da an Features und Funktionalität drin war, das hätte ich vielleicht auch eingebaut. Aber ich hätte jetzt nicht damit gerechnet, dass es ein Endkundenprodukt drin ist. Von daher sind zumindest manche der Teile offenbar doch durchaus brauchbar.
Dann immer?
Und bei diesen Geräten wird es eigentlich erst dann brandgefährlich, wenn man mal von so Kleinigkeiten absieht wie Bugs. Da muss halt auch ein Firmware-Update machen. Das kommt immer davor. Also QNAP hat jetzt letztens was, einen sehr schönen und schönen Incident gehabt. Aber das passiert halt laufend. Da hilft einfach nur updaten und diese Geräte können noch mittlerweile dir sagen, hier gibt ein Update, mach doch mal. Das heißt, das geht eigentlich schon sehr bequem. Wo es problematisch wird, ist, dass die letztendlich ja auch nur Computer sind und sich dementsprechend auch aktualisieren lassen. Da gibt es dann so Community-Apps, was nichts anderes ist als PAP-Myatmen oder so, die irgendwie als Pakete mit installierbar sind, nachträglich. Also du kannst dieses Gerät erweitern von einer reinen Datei-Ablage-Lösung zu einem kleinen Heim-Server mehr oder weniger und immer weiter ausbauen. Da gibt es fast keine Grenzen mehr heutzutage.
Das kann auch so ein E-Mail-Server sein.
Genau, ein Web-Server, wo man dann über sogenanntes, ich sag's nicht, ich schmeiß mal ins Raum Port Forwarding, auch vom Internet aus erreichbar machen kann. Und da wird es dann halt natürlich schnell beliebig anfällig. Das heißt, du machst das dann vom Internet aus direkt erreichbar ohne VPN. Das heißt, jeder kommt da drauf. Das klingt erstmal sehr bequem, aber das bedeutet halt auch, du hast sofort eine viel größere Angriffsfläche oder viel mehr Leute, die versuchen würden, da anzugreifen. Und das bedeutet halt auch, du benutzt ein Gerät für viele Zwecke. Und wie wir gerade auch schon besprochen haben, je mehr Zwecke ein Gerät erfüllt, umso angreifbar ist es.
Und das ist mehr Schmerz, wenn es nicht geht.
Genau, und so das ist halt die andere Sache.
Also seine Backup-Festparte sollte man nicht als Mehl-Server benutzen. Okay, jetzt gibt es ja immer diesen Zwiespalten. Also es gibt die Cloud und die hat sozusagen eine ganz praktische Eigenschaft ist, man hat halt Daten irgendwo und die werden automatisch synchronisiert. Und dazu könnte man so einen NAS auch benutzen. Man hat zu Hause eine Festplatte, da legt man Daten drauf, da kommt man von außen ran und dann gibt es irgendwie so verschiedene Programme, die auch man sagen kann, hier synchronisiere mal diesen Ordner auf meinem Rechner mit dem Ordner auf diesem NAS.
Das gibt es ja schon von den Anbietern der NASen.
Lassen sie mich bitte mal eine Frage zu unterstellen. Wir haben jetzt gerade schon gesagt, man kann das so einrichten, dass man von außen über das Internet auf diese Dinge zugreift. Man kann natürlich auch, was wir schon gelernt haben, über VPN ins Heimnetzwerk geben. Und dann sehe ich da natürlich meinen NAS. Was ist die bevorzugte Lösung?
Also wenn er sagt, das gibt es auch von den Herstellern, ich bin mir erstens nicht sicher, ob ich die Software von dem Hersteller auf meinem Rechner laufen lassen möchte. Und dann zweitens bin ich mir vergleichsweise sicher, dass es die nicht für meinen Rechner gibt.
Aber wie ist das denn jetzt mit so...
Es gibt da eine Hand voll offener Standards. Ja, es gibt immer eine Hand voll offener Standards, die man dann benutzen kann, die von solchen Geräten auch unterstützt werden.
Okay, aber gibt es sozusagen konkret eine Lösung? Also gerade für die Ordner-Synchronisation, wo man sagen kann, dass das funktioniert zwischen Rechner und NAS?
Du kannst als Third-Party-Apps auch irgendwie OnCloud, Nextcloud oder so was installieren. Und da gibt es ja auch relativ viel Client Support und Webinterface.
Will ich das?
Wenn du das übers VPN machst, ist das ja nichts anderes als... Also da hast du deine Angriffsfläche klein gehalten. Wenn du halt mit dem Updaten hinterher bist und ich kann leider nichts über den Stack unten drunter sagen, also irgendwie PHP-Version oder so, aber wenn du die App selber aktuell hältst, kannst du es notfalls auch ins Internet stellen. Aber VPN, du willst VPN.
Okay, also ich würde sowas wie OnCloud sowohl auf dem NAS installieren als auch auf meinem Rechner, das würde aber nur funktionieren, wenn ich über VPN zu mir nach Hause telefoniere.
Genau, aber das kannst du bei fast allen modernen Geräten konfigurieren, dass eine bestimmte VPN-Verbindung immer aktiv sein soll.
Ah ja, auch auf Telefonen.
Nur so die Geräte mit dem Obst haben da manchmal.
Ich dachte, da geht es sogar noch besser als auf allen anderen. Also hatte ich zumindest immer mir so gemerkt.
Telefone haben das.
Also auch die Obst-Telefone bei Dingen ist glaube ich sogar noch besser als bei den anderen. Achso, Computer weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß, dass es bei den Obst-Telefonen etwas besser geht als bei den Roboter-Telefonen, glaube ich.
Das mag sein. So, jetzt haben wir also dieses NAS da drin zu hängen und da sind die Fertiglösungen auch schon ganz brauchbar. Und was wollen wir denn noch machen? Also wir können, was man natürlich sagen kann, und wir verlassen jetzt mal sozusagen das Wesen des Heimanwenders, jetzt irgendwie das Technik sozusagen eigene Services zu betreiben, also den eigenen Web-Server. Mal abgesehen davon, dass ich dann, also dass ich sagen, selbst bei einem dickeren VDSL-Anschluss nicht will, dass da sehr viele Leute gleichzeitig drauf zugreifen, will ich das überhaupt, also will ich den Web-Server zu Hause betreiben?
Du hast grundsätzlich das Problem, dass bei einem, dass DSL, also gerade VDSL-Anschlüsse sind halt auch so ein bisschen je nachdem tageszeitabhängig. Das ist bei DSL nicht so schlimm wie bei zum Beispiel Kabel, hab ich gehört.
Ich kann das Gegenteil berichten.
Okay, im Endeffekt hängt das halt sehr, hast du halt das Problem, dass du eine sowieso schon schmale Leitung hast, die halt viel zu schmal ist. Also angenommen, du willst nur welche deinen Blog da hosten und du wirst jetzt irgendwo vertwittert und kriegst auf einmal ganz ganz viele Besucher dann und du hast nicht noch irgendwie ein Content-Delivery-Network irgendwie davor hängen, was die Bandbreite, die dann auf deinen Server landet, reduziert, kriegst du sehr schnell halt das Problem, dass deine 20 Megabit Upstream, die dein VDSL vielleicht kann, einfach schon ausreichen. Also bei mir wäre das halt so das Ende der Leitungskapazitäten. Also du kriegst halt sehr schnell einfach das Problem, dass deine Anbindung dann zu schmal ist und oder zu unzuverlässig. Dazu kommt das Problem, dass du bei Endkunden Anschlüsse im Allgemeinen wechselnde IP-Adressen hast, die sich wenigstens alle paar Wochen mal einfach wechseln. Da kann man dann irgendwie als Hack mit einem dünnen DNS Service auch von draußen drauf zugreifen. Aber insgesamt ist es so eine Sache, das kann man machen. Das ist vielleicht irgendwie für die drei Freunde okay, aber im Endeffekt...
Ich wollte mal sagen, dieser dünnen DNS Service, also um das zu kurz zu erklären, es gibt eine Möglichkeit, sozusagen Router machen das auch. Das ist ein Zusammenspiel zwischen man braucht einen Anbieter, der das für einen übernimmt und der Router muss das sagen können. Da kann man das so einstellen, dass automatisch kommuniziert wird, welche IP-Adresse hat der in der Anschluss gerade und dann gibt es eine Web-Adresse.
Genau, also das ist halt aus der Zeit entstanden, als die Telekom noch Endkunden keine Standleitung geben wollte und einfach jede Nacht einmal die Leitung durchgeschnitten hat. Das haben sie zum Glück aufgegeben, den Unfug mittlerweile, aber es ändert sich halt trotzdem ab und zu mal nach Stromausfall, wenn du am Kabel wackelst und was auch immer.
Und das wollte ich gerade sagen, so als Setting, also dieses irgendwie, okay, ich will ja nicht eine Webseite betreiben, wo vielleicht irgendwie mehr als fünf oder zehn Leute drauf zugreifen, aber so was wie, ich möchte eine gemeinsame Bildergalerie haben und ich traue halt nicht Flickr, Google, was auch immer, Dropbox, was auch immer das ist, sondern ich möchte das halt zu Hause über so ein Webinterface machen. Da würde ich schon gerne noch mal eine Einschätzung haben. Ist das das, wo man dann sagt, da macht man es dann doch, man kümmert sich selber und die Software sowas, oder ist das, wo ihr sagt, so nee, die technische Unzudenklichkeit und die Gefahr, da was Falsches zu machen, so groß, dass man doch lieber zu einem Cloud-Anbieter geht?
Ich würde sagen, Web-Server, gerade auch für solche Zwecke selber zu betreiben zu Hause, finde ich eher grenzwertig. Allein aus dem gesamten Unzufälligkeits-Ding. Und so teuer ist einfach ein virtuellen Server irgendwo zu mieten jetzt auch nicht. Ob das jetzt 5 oder 7 Euro sind. Und dann hat man alle Features, alles selber machen, alles wie vorher. Bloß man hat eine bessere Internetanbindung.
Ja, aber vom Sicherheitsgedanken würde ich das mal fragen wollen. Also ein virtueller Server, den ich mir miete. Das ist mal abgesehen davon, es gibt ja so NAS-Geräte, da kann man das einfach per Klick installieren, einen virtuellen Server.
Ja, aber die hängen wieder hinter der gleichen Internetverbindung.
Aber sozusagen ist es noch mal ein bisschen kompliziert zu bedienen. Aber von diesem Aspekt, das Ding steht bei mir zu Hause und physikalisch hab nur ich zu Griff. Und ein virtueller Server, das ist ein Rechner in einem Rechenzentrum, wo außerdem noch viele hundert andere Kunden drauf sind.
Also da ist halt grundsätzlich die gleiche Fragestellung, bietet sich da an wie bei allen Selbstmachprojekten. Die Frage ist, weniger kann das sicherer sein, sondern wirst du das in der Praxis besser machen, als wer auch immer du dafür bezahlen würdest. Und da würde ich sagen, im Allgemeinen, wenn es jetzt nicht um hochsensitive Daten geht, würde ich tatsächlich in Richtung Cloud gucken, weil die Cloud-Anbieter, ich meine klar, das ist nicht toll, dass deine Daten dann auf jemand anderes Computer liegen, deren du nicht unter deiner Kontrolle hast. Aber im Endeffekt ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die wissen, was sie tun und dafür sorgen, dass niemand deine Kundendaten klaut. Wenn du denen nur 5 Euro im Monat, ja, Henrik gibt Kontra. Wenn du denen nur einen 5er Monat rüberschiebst, schon ist der Wortwitz. Selbst wenn du denen nur einen 5er Monat rüberschiebst, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die das richtig machen, meiner Meinung nach in vielen Fällen immer noch höher, als dass du das richtig machst, wenn du nicht von dir aus schon Spaß an der Sache hast.
Also da muss man jetzt aber auch noch ein bisschen unterscheiden zwischen Cloud und was auch immer ein virtuelles Server, also was wir unter Cloud verstehen. Weil die 5 Euro sind jetzt ein virtuelles Server, den ich selber betreibe, da kann ich dann irgendeine Software installieren, so ein On-Cloud-Nex-Cloud heißt das glaube ich jetzt, mit automatischem Update und alles wird gut. Und habe trotzdem dieses, was da oben steht, mit dem Dezentralität fördern. Weil das jetzt alles bei einem der drei großen Anbieter, auf wie auch immer deren Imaging-Plattform heißt, hoch zu tun, finde ich jetzt auch nicht so schlau. Abgesehen davon, dass es dann auch wieder nicht am guten Internet ist, weil das ist dann am anderen Ende des Atlantiks.
Man kann festhalten, von den drei Lösungen, nämlich zu einem richtigen Cloud-Anbieter zu gehen oder sich einen eigenen Server zu klicken oder es zu Hause zu betreiben, ist die mittlere Lösung, nämlich einen eigenen Server zu klicken, also einen virtuellen Server, die man machen soll. Es sei denn, man hat den Spaß am basteln. Also es ist nicht so, dass ihr komplett davon abratet und sagt...
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Also wenn du daran Spaß hast, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass du das gut machen kannst. Weil es ist jetzt nicht wirklich schwer, das richtig zu machen. Ich meine im Endeffekt, alles was ein guter Anbieter für dich machen wird, ein Großteil davon ist halt einfach nur immer schön Updates machen, immer schön Backups machen. Und wenn man das macht, gibt es nicht so viel mehr. Je nachdem, was man da natürlich für Technologie einsetzt, aber zum Beispiel sowas wie OnCloud, gibt es nicht so viel mehr, was man großartig falsch machen kann. Nur das Risiko ist halt, wenn du eigentlich nicht eine OnCloud administrieren willst, sondern wenn du eigentlich nur deine Fotos irgendwo ablegen möchtest, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass du in vier Monaten oder so, wenn das nächste Update rauskommt, vielleicht einfach keinen Bock hast oder es nicht merkst und dann halt deine OnCloud nicht mehr sicher ist.
Wer OnCloud Horrorgeschichten hören will, dem empfehle ich einen Blick in mein Twitter Archiv.
Aber die andere interessante Lösung, nämlich Nummer vier, ist einfach nicht alleine machen, sondern wenn wir jetzt diesen Gedanken Dezentralität fördern wollen, ich habe zum Beispiel Infrastruktur, die ich mit Freunden teile. Also ich administriere das und benutze dafür. Und andere Leute dürfen bei mir dafür zum Beispiel meine Plattform, die ich für Blogs und Podcasts aufgesetzt habe, mit nutzen für ihre Blogs und Podcasts. Umgekehrt, ich stehe das bei dir zu Hause? Nee, steht auf einem virtuellen Server. Aber es geht jetzt um dieses Dezentralität fördern. Wir müssen hier alles in der Cloud machen. Umgekehrt, ich benutze der DNS, also diese IP zur Namensauflösung, Infrastruktur, auch von Bekannten. Das mache ich wiederum nicht selber, weil ich halt weiß, dass ich kann nicht alles selber machen. Und das ist so geteiltes Leid des Halbes Leid und man lernt halt auch relativ viel und man kommt halt nicht in die Verlegenheit, alles machen zu müssen und Hilfe. Mir wächst alles über den Kopf. Also das ist jetzt wirklich nur das Plädoyer für, macht auch mal was selber, traut euch, aber seid euch auch immer bewusst, wenn auch irgendwo sind halt die Grenzen eurer Leistung. Deswegen ist es sinnvoll, sich solche Aufgaben irgendwie zu teilen und so an Service Grenzen lässt sich das ganz gut machen. Du machst den Teil, ich mach den Teil oder man kann sich auch zusammensetzen. Wir administrieren das Ganze beide zusammen. Dann ist dieser, jemand kommt unter den Bus, wie schlimm ist das Faktor? Vielleicht etwas geringer, wenn mehr als eine Person weiß, wie man so ein Service administriert.
Man hat natürlich auch noch den Vorteil, dass man mit Freunden einen E-Mail-Server teilt, und der geht nicht. Dann hat man einen sehr guten Antrieb, den wieder gehen zu machen.
Also ja, ich betreibe auch eigentlich alle Services, die ich benutze selber, auf einem gemieteten Server, wo ich eine metrische Tonne virtuell Maschinen drauffahren lasse. Und ich mach das halt auch nicht nur für mich. Ich hab da so einen Verein befreundet, für den ich dann auch die Website und das ganze Zeug da noch mit drauf habe und dann halt alles, was ich selber benutze. Aber das ist jetzt, wir sind auf dem falschen Ende der Seite der Internetverbindung.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, lass uns zurückkehren ins Heimnetzberg. Da haben wir jetzt den Nas zu stehen. Das Nas, die Nas. Die Nas. Was denn noch, was stellen wir da noch so hin?
Die Glühbirne.
Oder ein paar davon ja. Wirklich?
Und den Ofen. Und den Isar. Und das Radio. Das Internet of Things.
IOT ist ja diese Abkürzung. Jaja, IOT ist short for Internet of Things that shouldn't be on the Internet.
Aber es macht trotzdem Spaß wahrscheinlich, oder?
Auf ein mobiler Art und Weise.
Das ist wie beim Sex, auf ordentlichen Schutz achten. Also ich hab da auch so ein Kondom zu Hause, dass ich also...
Ich hab auch das Bild, wie du eine Glühlampe in deinem WLAN erlogst und da dein Gummi drüber ziehst. Dabei ist wahrscheinlich nicht was passiert.
Das Gummi muss über die Kontakte.
Was eigentlich macht die Glühbohr in deinem WLAN?
Ja, das wissen wir auch nicht wirklich.
Na ja, also in einem so modernen Haushalt sind Lichtschalter so ein bisschen out. Das hat mehrere Gründe. Einer der Gründe ist, dass ich zum Beispiel bei mir am Bett habe ich Lampen. Ich habe auch so ein Deckenlicht, das habe ich kürzlich auch gelernt, das ist eigentlich auch fast nur in Deutschland verbreitet, dass man so eine Deckenbeleuchtung hat. In anderen Ländern ist es meistens eigentlich nur Standlampen. Dafür ist der Schalter aber neben der Tür. Nur ist die Tür vom Bett ein bisschen weit weg. Wenn ich also das Deckenlicht ausmache und zum Bett gehe, ist das doof. Umgekehrt, wenn ich an meinem Bett die angebrachten Lampen mache und zur Tür gehe, ist das doof.
Ich verstehe die Motivation, aber wieso sind diese Geräte im WLAN?
Weil der Schalter, mit dem ich das jetzt an und aus mache, den habe ich um den Arm. Ich habe so eine Uhr, wenn ich da eine der Knöpfe drücke, dann kommuniziert die mit meinem Handy, mein Handy kommuniziert mit meinem WLAN, kommuniziert mit der Heimautomatisierung und macht das Licht an und aus.
So, jetzt haben wir ja gerade schon darüber gesprochen, dass...
Und wenn ich gehe, dann macht die Heimautomatisierung das Licht auch aus, eines dieser Dinge.
Also früher war das tatsächlich mal komplett getrennt. Da gab es also irgendwie ein Bussystem, mit dem alle Geräte irgendwie miteinander geredet haben. Und da gab es dann einen sogenannten Gateway und der ging dann Richtung Internet. Und alles, was man tun musste, war quasi diesen Gateway irgendwie sauber zu halten. Das Problem ist, dass es dann wieder so ist.
Also warte mal, man hatte zu Hause einen Computer stehen, sag ich jetzt mal.
Genau.
Der hat sozusagen über etwas, was kein normales Netzwerk ist oder zumindest nichts mit dem normalen Netzwerk zu tun hatte, war der verbunden mit allen Geräten und den hat man dann angesteuert. Genau.
Das gibt es auch immer noch, aber es ist viel, viel, viel zu teuer.
Mittlerweile ist es sozusagen so, deswegen heißt es Internet of Things, dass jedes Ding selber am Netz ist.
Also das hat halt damit einzugehalten, dass die WLAN-Chips wesentlich günstiger wurden.
Aber die Frage, die ich jetzt habe, ist, wir haben ja gerade schon darüber gesprochen, dass ich bei meinem NAS entscheiden kann, also bohre ich da ein Loch in meinen Router und dann ist er von außen zugreifbar? Oder gehe ich übers VPN rein? Wie ist denn das mit diesen Internet of Things Sachen?
Ja, deswegen war ich beim C4Six.
Ja, also das Ding bei Internet of Things Sachen ist halt grundsätzlich das Problem, das wir momentan haben. Ich weiß jetzt, das war wahrscheinlich in der letzten Folge schon breitgetreten worden, ist, dass im Allgemeinen, wenn du so ein Gerät kaufst, kriegst du ein relativ modernes Stück Hardware mit einem fünf Jahre alten Linux Kernel und einem, wenn du Glück hast, weniger als fünf Jahre alten UserLand, wo ganz viel alte Software drauf läuft, die niemals ein Update erfahren wird. Du kriegst eine hast dich dahin geklatschte Android App. Und im Endeffekt ist der so State of the Art, wenn man sich mal umschaut, was die, vor allem die Firma von diesen Geräten angeht, häufig wirklich nicht das, was man eigentlich haben möchte.
Und vor allen Dingen nicht in seinem Netz haben möchte.
Ja, das heißt, man will so, also als Min, ich weiß nicht, das hängt natürlich ein bisschen davon ab, was man für Ansprüche an sein Netzwerk hat. Aber ich würde sagen, wenn man einen Gast-WLAN hat, dann sollte man auch einen IoT-WLAN haben, weil die durchschnittliche Internet-Klüböne vermutlich weniger sicher ist, als der durchschnittliche Windows-Rechner, der auf dem aktuellen Stand was Updates angeht, ist.
Deswegen mein Plädoyer an alle Router-Hersteller, wenn ihr ein innovatives Feature möchtet, bietet einen IoT-WLAN an. Und der zentrale Unterschied zu einem Gast-WLAN ist, ich möchte in der Lage sein, die Bandbreite bei diesem IoT-WLAN zu beschränken. Denn wenn so ein Ding mal gehackt wird, erstens soll es mich alarmieren, wenn auf einmal riesen Traffic dort herrscht. Und zweitens möchte ich einfach, dass diese Geräte nicht die Möglichkeit haben, mit voller Gewalt ins Internet zu pusten. Das ist nämlich genau das, was normalerweise passiert, wenn so ein Gerät, haben wir gerade gesagt, das ist eigentlich nur ein Linux-Computer drin letztendlich. Und wenn das Ding übernommen wird, weil es furchtbar alt ist und jeder weiß, wie man so ein Ding ownt, dann soll der Schaden möglichst begrenzbar sein. Und das machen die Hersteller dieser Geräte einfach nicht.
Oder es gibt vergleichsweise wenig Gründe, warum das Ding überhaupt eine Internetverbindung haben sollte. Also der Anwendungszweck, dass ich jetzt hier sitze und bei mir zu Hause Lampen an- und ausmache, ist grenzwertig sinnvoll. Das kann ich, wenn ich es möchte, immer noch über das VPN machen. Aber dass die App, die auf meinem Telefon läuft, sich zu einem Server des Herstellers verbindet und sich das Gerät auch zu dem Server des Herstellers verbindet, vorzugsweise mit einem Standardpasswort, und dann die Steuerung über Bande über den Hersteller stattfindet, ist eher sinnlos. Was ich bei mir deswegen zu Hause habe, ist, dass ich eine eigene SSID für nur die Internet-auf-Dings-Geräte habe.
Aber das heißt, du hast da noch einen Router dastehen?
Genau. Ich hab nämlich tatsächlich, mein WLAN kommt nicht aus meinem, ich hab tatsächlich eine von diesem Hersteller mit dem Ausrufezeichen, sondern da hab ich das WLAN ausgemacht. Ich hab noch mal so einen eigenen Access Point gekauft. Jetzt nicht die teure Variante, wie es hier zum Beispiel hängt, wo mehrere Access Points miteinander spielen, sondern nur eine. Aber der hat schon das Feature, dass er mehrere unterschiedliche WLAN-Namen aufmachen kann, die auf mehrere unterschiedliche VLANs geben kann.
Was ist ein VLAN?
Virtuelles LAN. Also ich kann auf dem gleichen Kabel mehrere fast physikalisch untereinander getrennte Netze fahren, die sich nicht gegenseitig sehen. Das ist der Haupttrick. Und dann habe ich das, also deswegen kommen bei mir zu Hause so viele Geräte zusammen. Dann habe ich das über mehrere Zwischengeräte. Liegt das dann auf einem Rechner, der davon Firewall technisch nur manches ins Heimnetz lässt und nichts ins Internet.
Wow, warte mal, also deine Internet of Things Geräte sind in dein extra Netzwerk eingesperrt?
Genau, von dem aus sie nicht ins Internet kommen. Wenn sie das versuchen, gibt es sogar ein Log-Eintrag und wird alarmiert. Bei einem der Geräte habe ich das Logging schon ausgemacht, weil das viel zu laut ist.
Aber wie steuert sie denn?
Mein Heimautomatisierungssteuerding hängt auch in diesem Netz. Und das hängt aber auch noch in meinem normalen Netz. Also die App auf meinem Telefon kann sich zu meiner Heimautomatisierung verbinden. Meine Heimautomatisierung kann sich zu dem Internet of Things-Gerät verbinden.
Und das kann die Glühweine ansteuern. Dann sind wir sozusagen an dem Punkt, wo ich sehe, wir haben sozusagen unser Default für heute verlassen. Das ist ja nicht mehr heimahmen, bin ja taugtäglich. Wir wollen gleich noch drüber sprechen, ob das überhaupt möglich ist. Was für ein gewaltiger Teaser. Und machen das nach der nächsten Musik. Die kommt von O'Neill, auch von einem Volume 7 Midwest Collective Sampler und heißt Lost Connection. Chaosradio, Chaosradio, Chaosradio 234. Wir reden über das Heimnetzwerk und naja, wie immer sozusagen gegen ein Internet Sendung denke ich so, ne, das mache ich alles nicht mehr. Ich ziehe den Internet Anschluss ab und dann ist es auch gut. Aber vielleicht ist es doch nicht ganz so schlimm.
Wir haben ja doch was mit Holz.
Doch was mit Holz. Holz oder Töpfern? Bücher über Töpfern. Da sollten wir mal ein Chaos Radio machen. Aber heute machen wir noch eine halbe Stunde zum Heimnetzwerk. Wir haben gerade angefangen, über das Internet of Things zu sprechen. Und naja, also das klingt erst mal schlimm. Henrik hat erzählt, dass er zu Hause viel Internet of Things hat, aber ein extra ein eigenes Netzwerk sozusagen eingerichtet hat, wo das alles eingesperrt ist. Und das ist natürlich sehr, was ich mich frage, kann ich das als Heimanwender überhaupt ein Internet of Things zu Hause haben, ein Thing of Internet, ohne dass ihr die Hände über den Kopf zusammenschlagt?
Na ja, wenn es nicht ganz so schlimm ist wie die meisten heutzutage. Also es gab da wohl kürzlich ein Gerät, das zumindest dadurch aufgefallen ist, dass es nicht ganz kaputt war. Es gibt da ein Hacker, der hatte sich der Reihe nach alle möglichen Internet of Things Geräte gekauft und Glühlamm und so weiter. Das ging vor drei Monaten dann mal ein bisschen durch die sozialen Medien, weil er bei Amazon einen Kommentar geschrieben hat und dann geschrieben bekam, bitte löscht den Kommentar, sonst verlier ich meinen Job, weil er halt drüber schrieb, was dieses Gerät so tut. Und der hatte sich kürzlich so ein IKEA Gerät, IKEA macht das jetzt auch, gekauft und meinte, also ist jetzt nicht offensichtlich kaputt, ne?
Warte, warte, warte. Das ist das Level, auf dem wir sind. Es ist eine positive Nachricht, wenn etwas nicht offensichtlich kaputt ist.
Also vor allen Dingen, weil sie es halt auch nicht so albern gebaut haben, wie manche dieser Lampen, dieses Magic Home oder so, wo halt die Lampe sich durch, das geht wie mit dem Internet, mit dem Server des Herstellers und dann die App auf deinem Telefon, mit dem Internet, mit dem Server des Herstellers. Und dann kannst du halt von hier, wie gesagt, das Licht zu Hause steuern oder auch von zu Hause. Das machen die Leute nicht, sondern sie haben wirklich bloß einen Service auf dem Gateway laufen, der wirklich nur für lokale Verbindungen da ist und das nicht über ein unsicheres Protokoll macht und auch mit sicherer Verschlüsselung und mit einem Passwort, das so aussieht, als ob es auch sicher wäre und wie gesagt halt nicht. Hab ich gestern getan. Zumindest testweise, aber ja. Also ich denke mal, das sah erstmal nicht schlecht aus.
Okay.
Dazu muss man sagen, ein interessanten, ja so ein bisschen Hintergrund zu diesem Ikea-Teil, das aus meinen Augen interessant daran ist vor allem, dass Ikea da denke ich unter den ersten großen Herstellern ist, die den, es gibt so eine Reihe von Protokollen für das Interfinks, die aus der IETF herauskommen, das ist so die Internet Engineering Task Force, das sind die, die an oder dazu mal so die ganzen Grundlagenprotokolle des Internets geschaffen haben.
Gibt es auch ein eigenes Chaosradio zu verlinken? Oder ein Blockboost?
Genau und die haben so eine Reihe von Protokollen, die für das IoT nutzbar sind gemacht und ich denke Ikea ist unter den ersten großen Herstellern, die diese Protokolle einsetzen. Das Problem bei Internet of Things ist, dass sehr viele Hersteller auch ihre eigenen Insellösungen bauen in der Hoffnung, dass alle Leute nur ihre Lösung kaufen und dann dort eingesperrt bleiben und nicht herauskommen, weil das soll ja alles miteinander weiter reden.
Naja oder der andere Grund ist, dass sie einfach das jetzt gleich machen wollen und sich dann einfach irgendwas runterschreiben. Also so Weitsicht bis zur Tischkante und dann ich programmiere das jetzt und morgen habe ich eh einen anderen Job und deswegen gibt es auch nie Updates.
Und bei der ITF müssen die müssen die sich halt auf den Standard einlegen und müssen sich überall gewisse Dinge Gedanken machen wie Security oder so.
Ja das interessante ist halt folgendes und zwar die Insellösungen waren dann zum einen ein Problem, dass die alle nicht miteinander reden und im Allgemeinen sehr schlecht Qualität haben. Dann gab es ja auch noch dieses SIGBI Ding. Das war was ein künstlerliederländischer Hersteller getan hat. Philips Huw verwendete das. SIGBI hatte allerdings halt das Problem, dass es, keine Ahnung, es hatte halt so ein bisschen das Problem, dass es so auf der physischen Ebene relativ schön war, aber so die Protokollebenden teilweise etwas dreckig waren. Vor allem halt war die ganze Verschlüsselungs- und Sicherungsangelegenheit teilweise etwas wenig elegant gelöst. Dazu kam dann noch, dass Philips sich natürlich, man kann nur spekulieren, aber was halt passiert ist, dass es irgendwie so geschehen ist, dass dann auf einmal Philips Geräte, obwohl sie eigentlich den herstellerübergreifenden Standard implementieren, nur noch mit anderen Philips Geräten redeten. Zumindest für einige Wochen, bis ihnen das zu peinlich wurde. Ich mein, kann mal passieren, die lernen halt auch, wie alle jetzt gerade erst mit dieser Technik klarzukommen. Ja, anyway, diese SIGB-Standards waren halt immer so ein bisschen, naja, man weiß nicht, wie gut die sind, vor allem wie sicher das alles nachher ist. Und das interessante denke ich an Ikea ist halt, dass sie unter den ersten sind, die halt diese wirklich offenen ITF-Standards einsetzen, an denen auch wohlgemerkt jeder mitarbeiten kann. Die Mailing-Listen, auf denen die entwickelt werden, sind offen, da kann man sich einfach subscriben, mitlesen und sogar kommentieren und mitarbeiten an diesen Standards, die da eingesetzt werden. Ich denke, das hat halt vielleicht Potenzial, dass das möglicherweise auch in drei Jahren noch funktioniert und möglicherweise sogar vielleicht von einer Herstellerin unterstützt wird.
Oder von offener Software.
Dann das wär ja mal was. So, jetzt haben wir also festgestellt, was wir im eigenen Heimnetzwerk haben wollen, ist ein Nas, aber keine Glühlampen. Also zumindest die meisten nicht. Haben wir noch was vergessen? Bestimmt.
Ach ja, es gibt da noch so Mediengeräte. Oh. So Streaming-Sticks und so. Die brauchen halt auch Internet.
Und Smart TVs und...
Ach ja, die sind ja noch schlimmer.
Und Verstärker, die Spotify...
Gut, die Smart TVs brauchen kein Internet?
Dürfen kann.
Also ich hab das tatsächlich so gelöst, ich habe ein sogenanntes Smart TV. Dann wurden irgendwann die Updates für dieses Smart TV eingestellt. Das war der Moment, wo dieses Smart TV bei mir zum DumpTV downgegradet wurde, indem ich den Netzwerkstecker gezogen habe. Und wenn es mich jetzt irgendwie nach Smarten-Inhalten und Netflix oder Amazon Prime oder was auch immer, es da für Anbieter gibt, gelöstet, dann mache ich das mit separater Hardware. Die gibt es ja von diversen Anbietern auch recht kostengünstig. Und die haben halt den Vorteil, also der Nachteil ist natürlich, ich bin, wenn ich da jetzt nichts komplett generisches kaufe, eigentlich immer darauf angewiesen, was der Hersteller will. Wenn ich mir jetzt einen Stick von Amazon kaufe, bin ich darauf angewiesen, dass Amazon in meinem Sinne handelt und nicht in seinem Sinne, was natürlich immer nur so beschränkter Fall ist. Dasselbe gilt für irgendwie ein Google Stick, wie auch immer, also ein Chromecast. Aber ich habe halt den Vorteil, diese Dinger kosten nur begrenzt viel Geld, im Gegensatz zu so einem komplett neuen Smart TV oder so. Und wenn das irgendwie doof ist, dann kann ich das weiterverkaufen, im schlimmsten Fall wegschmeißen. Und da ist nicht viel verloren gegangen. Und es ist zwar immer noch schlimm, dass man ein Gerät wegwerfen muss.
Weiterverkaufen ist aber schon ganz schön übel.
Schon hinterhältig. Aber wie gesagt, im schlimmsten Fall wirklich wegwerfen oder sonst irgendwas. Und es ist doof, immer doof, wenn man hat, wer wegwerfen muss. Aber ich finde, es ist im Vergleich zu ein komplettes TV-Gerät wegzuwerfen, jetzt auch nicht nur geldmäßig, sondern auch so umweltmäßig immer noch besser zu vertreten, so einen kleinen Stick wegzuwerfen.
Also jetzt noch in funktionierend am Start?
Nee, aber ich hab alles Ticks.
Die du dann bei Bedarf nur einschlägst oder sind die immer da?
Na ich hab auch so einen moderneren HDMI-Dingsbums, wo man halt mehrere HDMI-Eingänge hat. Der hängt auch am Netzwerk.
Aber in seinem eigenen?
In den Netflix-Media-Netzwerken? Nein, nein, also der hängt halt im normalen Netzwerk. Den kann ich auch mit der Fernbedienungs-App auf dem Telefon steuern. Das ist alles an meiner Heimat-Automatisierung dran, sodass das auch geräteübergreifend koordiniert werden kann. Das ist dann aber, glaube ich, eine andere Chaos-Radio-Sendung.
Aber das Gleiche gilt halt auch, du hast noch gefragt nach den Verstärkern, die Spotify machen oder Dollar-Streaming-Anbieter.
Also wir könnten da hier die Anekdote aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin anführen.
Ich hoffe darauf, dass das jetzt einer von euch tut.
Anekdoten aus dem eigenen Haus.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab ja eben schon mal gut vorgelegt mit irgendwie, ich sitze hier beim Chaos Radio und besitze selber irgendwie gerade etwas mehr als einen Computer. Wir sind ja hier im Chaos Computer Club Berlin und der Chaos Computer Club Berlin ist ja immer auf der Höhe der Zeit. Wir haben jetzt seit einiger Zeit schon eine Netzwerk-steuerbares Licht-Dings da für die Raumbeleuchtung und wir hatten seit einigen Jahren ein Netzwerk-verbundenes Verstärker-HDMI-Bild zum Beamer-Weiterleitungs-Audio-Quell-Umschaltungs-Multifunktions-Alles-Gerät.
Ich glaube, AV-Receiver ist die generische Bezeichnung von zu teilen.
Ich weiß nicht, die kurze Story ist, die Software, die auf diesem Gerät lief, war unglaublich schlecht und dieses Gerät hat im Endeffekt 3 oder 4 Jahre funktioniert, bis es dann irgendwann nicht mehr funktioniert hat. Das haben Leute versucht, Firmware-Updates zu machen, die dann irgendwie nicht funktioniert haben und da mussten Firmware-Updates rückgängig gemacht werden und es musste ständig neu konfiguriert werden, weil Leute irgendwie Sachen verfrickelt haben und inzwischen steht wieder der alte nicht IoT dumme Verstärker im Chaos Computer Club Berlin, weil wir es nicht hinkriegen.
Also ich muss sagen, ich hab das Vorgängermodell von der gleichen Firma, also das schlaue Vorgängermodell und bei mir zu Hause funktioniert.
Es scheint zufriedene Kunden zu geben, wir gehören nicht dazu.
Das ist das Geheimnis, dass nur einer versucht, die Firmware Updates aufzuhalten. Egal.
Naja, es muss erstmal Firmware Updates geben und einen anderen Receiver haben wir mal gekauft, weil die Freunde des Obstes hier gerne Airplay haben wollten und nur dieser einen Receiver konnte Airplay. Das Ganze hat irgendwie so lange gut funktioniert, bis Apple sich mal überlegt hat, den Airplay Standard umzuschmeißen. Also es war halt kein Standard, sondern halt irgendwie die Idee, wie Apple gerne das möchte. Und das war dann so ein Vierteljahr nach Kauf war diese Idee, dass man doch Airplay nicht auf einem separaten Gerät haben muss, dann auch hinüber und seitdem steht hier nebendran per HDMI angeschlossen, oder stand dann per HDMI angeschlossen, ein Airplayfähiges Extragerät. Also auch da lernen wir, smarte Devices, die alles können wollen, sind meistens nicht die Investition, die man sich hier hofft.
Und geschlossene Standards sind doof, lernen wir auch.
Das ist halt so ein Separation of Concerns Ding. Also ich denke gerade bei so was teurem, also ich mein bei dem WLAN-Router hatten wir das ja eben schon, da haben wir ja dann den Schluss gefasst so ein bisschen, dass die Geräte halt einfach nicht so teuer sind, dass man sich das jetzt nicht leisten könnte, notfalls das komplette Teil auszutauschen. Allerdings bei so was wie einem Fernseher oder auch einem teuren AV-Receiver, was an sich ja problemlos 10 Jahre halten kann, wenn nicht länger, weil es auch eine relativ einfache Aufgabe erfüllt. Ich meine, gut, der Fernseher ist jetzt schon etwas komplexer, der muss immerhin ein Bild anzeigen auf zwei Dimensionen, aber der AV-Receiver muss ja wirklich nur irgendwie auf vier, fünf Kanälen Audio raus tun. Für diese relativ einfache Aufgabe, wenn man sich so ein teures Gerät dahinstellt, dann will man vielleicht nicht unbedingt das dann noch koppeln mit ganz, ganz, ganz vielen anderen Dingen, die alle relativ unwichtig im Gesamtbild sind, wenn man diese anderen Dinge halt auch irgendwie separat kriegt. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir einen AV-Receiver hinstelle, dann will ich mir vielleicht lieber einen AV-Receiver holen, der möglichst wenig tut und ein separates Gerät zum Beispiel für Airplay, weil dann kann ich die beiden Teile unabhängig voneinander upgraden. Und wenn der AV-Receiver irgendwann scheiße ist, weil ich möchte mir größere Lautsprecher hinstellen, dann kann ich mir den austauschen und das Airplay-Device kann ich lassen. Während andererseits, wenn Apple sich das morgen anders überlegt und Airplay geht jetzt irgendwie auf einer anderen Portnummer oder was auch immer, kann ich halt auch nur dieses diskrete Device austauschen.
Jetzt wissen wir warum Henrik 22 Geräte hat.
Ja, da sind auch so ein paar Ähnliche dabei. Also ich hab irgendwie drei oder vier Raspberry-Pi's in der Gegend verteilt, um CO2-Messwerte aufzuzeichnen und mein Beamer zum Beispiel ist modern genug, um Computersteuerung zu haben, aber nicht so modern, als es IP hat, sondern es hat so einen seriellen Anschluss. Das heißt, der hängt auch an einem der Raspberry-Pi's dran und geht darüber dann in die Heimatomatisierung ein. Und ja, das summiert sich dann.
Da wollte ich natürlich auch noch fragen, wenn man jetzt basteln will, ist ja die Versuchung, sich vielleicht nochmal einen eigenen Rechner hinzustellen, der nur so eine Sache macht, vielleicht eine gute Versuchung. Und ist der Raspberry Pi jetzt irgendwie das Maß aller Dinge? Weil ich habe, würde sagen, auf einem harten Weg lernen müssen, dass man da auch Dinge falsch machen kann, mit denen man nicht rechnet. Zum Beispiel, wenn man das Betriebssystem, das man darauf installiert, auf USB-Sticks macht, dann können die relativ schnell kaputt gehen, weil die die vielen Schreibvorgänge nicht vertragen oder so. Also mit dem Kopf geschüttelt, nein, da kann man nichts falsch machen.
Also vielleicht grundsätzlich, was man sagen kann, ist, dass generell bei Raspberry Pi, wie bei ganz vielen anderen solchen Geräten gilt, dass es geschickt ist, wenn man einfach, wenn man vorausgesetzt, es passt zu den eigenen Anforderungen, wenn man das benutzt, was möglichst viele andere Leute auch benutzen. Und der Raspberry Pi ist halt unglaublich populär. Dementsprechend ist die Software, die man da so kriegt, wenn man das Teil einfach nur hinstellt und sich was irgendetwas runterlädt, irgendwie ein Debian oder Arch Linux oder was auch immer, man da drauf haben will, die ist ziemlich brauchbar. Gerade bei diesen Embedded-Geräten, die haben so ein bisschen das Problem, dass da alle sechs Monate ein neuer Chip rauskommt. Und jedes Mal, wenn ein neuer Chip rauskommt, hört der Hersteller im schlimmsten Fall auf, den alten Chips zu zertorten. Dazu kommt noch, dass generell diese Chips, wenn sie rauskommen, meistens so ein bisschen antike Software ab Werk mitbringen. Und sich die meisten Bordhersteller dann nicht die Mühe machen, die großartig anzupassen. Das heißt, da ist im Durchschnitt die Softwarequalität relativ gering, die man mit dem Gerät mitgeliefert kriegt. Und obwohl es ganz, ganz, ganz viele Alternativen zum Raspberry Pi gibt, von denen vor allem viele, viele günstiger sind, ist so, weiß jetzt nicht, es muss nicht der Raspberry Pi sein, aber zumindest ein vernünftig populäres Board, was keine Ahnung, eine gute Nutzerzahl weltweit hat.
Was gibt es da noch? Für mich ist das Ding sozusagen, also wenn ich mich sozusagen versuche damit zu beschäftigen, weiß ich das sozusagen technisch gesehen auch. Aber praktisch gesehen ist es für mich, was es aber anscheinend ja ist, nicht eine Gerätekategorie, kleine sozusagen Multifunktionscomputer, sondern es gibt halt den Raspberry Pi.
Ja, also es gibt halt, ich weiß nicht, es gibt zum Beispiel die von Olimex, die Olinoxino oder so heißen die Teile. Die sind, die hab ich gehört relativ gut. Es gibt die Beagle Board und Beagle Bone mit Texas Instruments Chips drauf. Die sind vor allem hardwaremäßig sehr, sehr, sehr cool. Also da kann man, da kann man, das Ding ist halt, der Raspberry Pi hat halt so ein mobil Telefon, primär für mobil Telefone entwickelten Chip drauf. Der kann ganz gut Video abspielen, aber der hat jetzt nicht so viele Hardware-Spielereien. Und währenddessen diese Beagle Bones, die haben dann von Texas Instruments Chips drauf, die wurden unter anderem für so Industriesteuerung und so Anwendungen in Autos entwickelt. Das heißt, die haben hardwaremäßig deutlich mehr Spielzeug mit dem dann, wenn man etwas tiefer in die Materie einsteigen will, man seinen Spaß haben kann.
Oder eine ganz andere Kategorie, wenn man jetzt weg will von diesen, das ist ja meistens armen, architekturbasierten Rechner, die auch sehr viel zum basteln sind, sondern wenn man jetzt die Anwendung hat, ich möchte jetzt keine Daten speichern, aber ich möchte so ein paar Dienste da drauf laufen lassen, dann ist immer noch so eine ganz gute Kategorie x86-kompatible passivgekühlte Rechner. Gibt zum Beispiel PC Engines, ist zum Beispiel ein Hersteller, der sowas baut. Das sind 64-bit Intel-kompatible CPUs. 64-bit Intel-kompatible, also das, was man auch durchaus, das ist das, was man...
Kein Mobiltelefon.
Kein Mobiltelefon, sondern eher die Architektur, die du in deinem Laptop hast.
Aber ist das dann auch sozusagen ein kleiner Computer als Gerät?
Das ist auch ein kleiner Computer, da kannst du...
Das ist einfach so groß wie so ein Router.
Genau, also so ist auch so eine kleine Box. Und das Schöne ist, die kannst du passiv kühlen, da musst du jetzt nicht irgendwie aufwendig, es ist sehr kompakt und du kannst dort tatsächlich auch Dienste laufen lassen. Und das ist ja gerade, wir haben gerade gesagt, du willst das meistens irgendwie nass haben. Und alles, was du nicht auf dem Nass laufen lassen willst, was jetzt nicht super rechneraufwendig ist, kannst du dort laufen lassen. Der Vorteil dabei ist, alles, was auf so einem normalen Computer läuft, läuft auch da im Gegensatz zu einem Platinencomputer, die meistens irgendwie ihr eigenes, angepasstes Linux irgendwie haben.
Wie ist das mit dem Stromverbrauch?
Genau, und das ist halt passiv gekühlt. Das heißt, du brauchst schon mal keinen Strom, der irgendwie so einen surrenden kleinen Lüfter laufen lässt. Es ist vielleicht, es tut sich nicht viel. Es ist wahrscheinlich, es braucht wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr. Ja, also da ist es halt auch wieder so ein Trade-off, was will ich. Wenn man lieber auf der PC-kompatiblen Schiene sein will und sagen, ich habe irgendwie keine Lust mit Arm und weiß nicht, auf was ich mich da einlasse, dann ist man mit solchen Boards wahrscheinlich deutlich besser beraten.
Und was du vorhin angesprochen hast, Probleme mit dem Flash-Speicher gibt, glaube ich, heutzutage nicht mehr.
Na toll, dann mach ich wieder die entscheidende Jahr zu früh.
Also ich habe es tatsächlich geschafft, beim Raspberry den Flash kaputt zu kriegen. Die sind nämlich modernerweise so, dass die Micro SD-Karten, mittlerweile die Micro SD-Karten, so ein Stückchen rausguckt.
Das habe ich auch schon geschafft.
Das ist mir aus einer, also ich hatte es an die Wand geklebt, weil das halt eines meiner Heimatautomatisierungs-Dinger war. Es ist runtergefallen und hat es tatsächlich geschafft, so drauf zu landen, dass die Micro SD-Karte damit durchgebrochen ist.
Ich habe literally meine Micro SD-Karte beim Aus-einem Raspberry Pi rauszuziehen versuchen abgebrochen.
Ich habe es mal geschafft, mit dem Ding als Hebel, mit den ganzen Reader rauszubrechen. Wer wissen möchte, wie man kostenlos oder kostengünstig einen Raspberry Pi SD-Kart Reader ersetzen will, kann bei mir im Blog vorbeigucken. Wir haben das hier im Club mal gemacht und ich habe das mal runtergeschrieben mit Bilderanleitung.
Zum Schluss, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das noch so kurz hinkriegen, aber es klang noch kurz an. Es gibt ja mittlerweile diese Assistenten, die auf dem V-Marsch sind, sowas wie ein Alexa von Amazon oder wer weiß, ob wir auch noch mal eine Siri zum hinstellen kriegen. Und heute ging es irgendwie durch, dass Amazon anscheinend daran arbeitet, eine Kamera ins Schlafzimmer zu kriegen, wie dann mich fotografieren und mir Kleidervorschläge machen soll.
Und die Daten nie wieder löschen will?
Und die Daten nie wieder löschen will. Ich würde mir aus grundsätzlichen Erwägungen so ein Ding nie in die Wohnung holen. Aber wie betreibt man so was? Macht man dann noch ein eigenes Netzwerk, das man dann nur anmacht, wenn man es benutzt? Oder wie läuft das?
Also ich hab so ein Alexa, einfach mal zu Testzwecken in dem IoT-LAN, WLAN hängen. Das hat halt auch nur eine Verbindung zu meiner Heimat-Dothematisierung und Internet blöderweise, weil das muss ja meine Sprache in den Sinn halten. Und kann aber ersetzen mir jetzt die Lichtschalter. Das ist so ungefähr der... Ich habe noch kein... Naja, du weißt ja, wie das mit Early Adopter ist. Mal so ausprobieren, was man damit tun kann. Ich habe keinen Anwendungsfall für einen Sprachassistenten gefunden, außer halt irgendwie Wecker und Licht. Aber alles, womit die so werben, ist halt so, ja, dann funktioniert die Spracherkennung nicht. Und da du ja kein Edit-Interface hast, musst du den gesamten Request wiederholen. Und das ist halt...
Also ich finde halt an diesen Assistenten vor allem interessant, dass wir halt da auch noch sehr stark, so finde ich, gesellschaftlich so ein bisschen lernen, damit umzugehen. Zum Beispiel eine Sache, die ich mir persönlich wünschen würde, also ich, das Closer, ich habe keinen solchen Assistenten zu Hause stehen und werde auch keinen zu Hause stehen haben, weil ich, weil da grundsätzlich ja das Problem ist, dass du den Dingern jetzt modulo, die Firmware, die da drauf läuft, nicht ansiehst, ob die jetzt gerade Sprache aufnehmen und ins Internet senden oder ob die gerade nichts tun. Das heißt, wenn du so einen Teil im Raum stehen hast, dann weißt du nicht, ob dieses Gerät jetzt gerade aufnimmt oder nicht. Und was ich jetzt mal einfach hier in den Raum stellen würde, ist, wenn ihr euch so einen Teil in den Raum stellt, dann überlegt euch doch mal, wenn ihr dann Leute zu Besuch habt, dann sagt denen das. Weil ich fände es tatsächlich komisch, wenn ich in einem Raum mit jemandem, gerade bei jemandem zu Hause, irgendwie was Privates bespreche und dann erfahre ich ja, hier steht das Internet of Things im Raum und hat uns zugehört.
Ja, deswegen habe ich das so gefragt zu sagen, weil im Prinzip will man für so eine Dinge an den Ausschalter.
Das gibt es im Prinzip. Ich habe so ein neues Fire TV da. Da gibt es das. Da muss man erst auf eine Taste drücken. Das Problem ist, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das Ding nicht trotzdem zuhören kann.
Also bei dem Fire TV ist es nicht ganz so schlimm, weil es ist akkubetrieben, also die Fernbedienung.
Es gab ja vor ein paar Jahren schon so einen ähnlichen Fall. Und zwar gab es da, ich glaube auf dem Chaos Communication Congress, einen Vortrag, wo sie in der Lage waren, ein Cisco IP-Telefon, so ein Telefon, was irgendwie über Internet Telefonie macht, was so ein Speakerphone, also eine Freisprechfunktion hatte, so zu hacken, dass der Mikrofon von der Freisprecheinrichtung aktiv sein konnte, ohne dass die Hardware-Lampe, die das Teil eingebaut hatte, die signalisiert, dass das Mikrofon an ist, anging. Das hatte halt wirklich diese Lampe für so Unternehmen, damit man sich da sicher sein kann, dass das Gerät nicht aufnimmt und das Konten sie umgehen. Und ich denke, genau das ist das Problem bei jeder Lösung, wo so ein Gerät einen Du-darfst-aufnehmen-Schalter hat. Man muss halt darauf vertrauen, dass der Hersteller, ob aus Blödheit oder bösem Wille, das nicht falsch implementiert hat und dieser Schalter auch wirklich das tut, was draus steht. Was man natürlich machen kann, ist, man könnte die Idee haben, dass Amazon Echo dann an eine WLAN-Steckdose hängen und dann...
Und wir müssen uns zukünftig dann gewöhnen, analog zu den Kreditkarten, die wir jetzt alle in eine Hülle packen müssen, die Fernbedienung vom Amazon Fire TV in eine goldene Schatulle einzugraben.
Also da sehe ich das Problem ein bisschen kleiner, weil schon der Dashbutton hatte ja auch ein Mikrofon drin. Das sind aber beides akkubetriebene Geräte. Also selbst wenn das jemand von ferner hackt, ist halt die Aufzeichnungszeit eher begrenzt. Das Problem bei so einem Echo und bei so einem was auch immer ist halt doch schon, dass die strombetrieben sind. Und wenn die Firmen entsprechend böse es beliebig lange aufnehmen können, da wäre vielleicht interessant, dass wir in Zukunft Lösungen entwickeln, dass man mal den Internetverbrauch überwacht. Das ist natürlich auch nicht todsicher, weil das könnte ja Daten komprimieren und dann burstmäßig senden. Aber es wäre zumindest peinlich für den Hersteller, wenn das Ding dauerhaft Daten raussendet, obwohl es gar nicht rot leuchtet.
Na gut, ich nehme auf jeden Fall mal mit. Ich will mir so ein Ding bei Zeiten noch nicht in die Wohnung stellen. Und wenn, dann nur mit so einem Hardware-Click-Clack-An-Aus-Schalter, was natürlich total geil ist, weil dann geht man an den Tisch, macht so Klick und sagt dann so Jetzt möchte ich aber was sagen. Dann hätte ich es auch schon schnell eingetippt. Aber wir müssen jetzt zum Ende der Sendung kommen. Vielen Dank Danimo, Jasik und Henrik, dass wir einen kleinen Einblick gehabt haben, was man in einem Netzwerk machen kann und was man besser lassen sollte. Wie ich mal wieder gelernt habe, ist das der größere Teil dieser ganzen Geschichte. Wir verabschieden uns damit. Was habe ich gelernt? Also keinen digitalen Assistenten, Glühböen nur in einem extra Netzwerk.
Überhaupt Netzwerke trennen?
Überhaupt Netzwerke trennen. Und man sollte auf jeden Fall einen NAS dabei haben, denn das gilt auch nach diesem Chaosradio. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Und schön Backups machen. Genau.